Henry I know moving to a new house can
be a little scary but you'll get used to
it
our son has taken to this doll in a way
that we find perhaps a bit odd but it
seems to be therapeutic
[Music]
tap and check your phone
you [__] miss me okay shopping you
want to play Let's Play
hold on hold on
hold on Rising
you're not the producer from Deep line
where is my sister Chucky Tucker
help Caroline you don't have to do this
I'm his new friend of the end knife drop
if you see the news is that Chucky in
the white house we're responsible for
Chucky we're going to DC he knows where
my sister is we're gonna kill Chucky
guys
again he's a cure no White House
[Applause]
[Music]
I think you found the Oval Office very
interesting
[Music]
what are you guys talking about killing
people what the [__]
tonight we bring you the story of how
David Beckham
became a global phenomenon
[Applause]
I never really did well at school
because all I ever wanted to do was play
football
[Music]
my manager kept saying try and keep it
under wrap so we would meet in car parks
and that's not as easy as it sounds
classy I suppose that most blogs have
looked at the television so I like her
don't [__] end up with them
my life have become something different
we were worried to eat lose all what
he'd work for because football come
first and all of a sudden it wasn't a
big smile it definitely didn't change me
we changed there's no doubt with that
okay
there's a red card for David Beckham
I don't think I've ever talked about it
just because I can't
I wasn't eating I wasn't sleeping it
took a toll on me that
I never even knew myself
Ferguson admitted he had kicked the boot
accidentally striking Beckham and then
I've gone like that and then I've gone
like that you went at him yeah it's
really entertaining when the surface
comes to town right unless you're in it
we were drowned but he just kept going
I don't give up easy it's Beckham
I don't give up
I felt very vulnerable and alone
we honest I I am being honest
who are you gonna kick it like
if I told him how good he was then he's
got nothing to work at I remember saying
to Bex saying [__] you on our team what
do you do afterwards sink or swim
there was something inside of that
determination
[Music]
you haven't seen nothing yet
there's more to come
Maybe
[Music]
I let him down I should have just told
him how I feel I will find him Oh
Captain you know that fear is going to
murder you
what no why would he do that you dumped
him I didn't dump him he died yes no
we're on a break
only the same blanket like this
I heard him pretty bad pretty bad yeah I
had a very rough night last night
it's a new day no more booze no more
drugs and more importantly no more Steed
hello Edward
hi what you two know each other
Shipmates
former
gentlemen the end of piracy
something's wrong is wrong there's like
a storm's coming
the entire Escape relies on this we've
only got one shot
nope I can't do it I've never even seen
one of these
[Music]
I've been a failure my whole life
it's not so bad once you get used to it
you're going through that if I was a
regular dude phase I feel like I've just
found my new best friend
no you are still alive
I cannot say
I do ask myself that question every day
find love a good Pirate's tale
you don't know the first thing about
piracy
it's all about Glory
something
Blackbeard are you poor now a foot no
I'm just just trying something different
man okay
Back to Basics
[Music]
obey
hello
we have a little bit of a situation we
wanted to run by you Mobius wow
wow that that's what's been happening
wow time slipping were you times you
know that yeah you've seen that yeah can
you fix that no
it's impossible to time slipping the TVA
I know but we just saw it happen
[Music]
I've been pulled through time
pass and the present hello
if what I saw is true
I think the stand between this world and
other destruction only one way to find
out
little good old-fashioned leg work
listen we have different styles you're a
man of action which is fine
I take a more slow deliberate cerebral
approach
really good buy
[Music]
it's up to us
to save this place is this cracked okay
whatever we do
we're playing God
we are gods
but how do you choose
who lives
and who dies
make the hard choice
[Music]
always have been
always will be
all over the top don't you think
I thought it was spot on
the best time
best time
it's time
[Music]
your honor no matter how much evidence
stacked against them the Usher crime
family stand stronger and darker than
ever before
anyone comes after us we will exhaust
our Arsenal until the threats neutralize
by neutralize two men suit and to
Oblivion on the streets neutralize like
dead depends we really should get
together more often it's just a bomb for
the soul
remember
your family is a collection of stunted
Hearts this time has gone
who are you
consequence
and tonight is consequential
thank you
[Music]
I'm gonna head out I've got an
appointment with your dad
my brother's dead this is tragic but a
few My Heart Will Go On tweets we'll Pat
it out this was an all accident you have
been targeted and this woman knows
everything it's time Roger what did you
do I'm afraid your ringside for my
Reckoning old friend I don't even own
anything funeral black wait that's not
true it's just [__] Saturn Saturn is
silk for poor people and no one should
wear it to a funeral unless they died in
it
safe
stop her
I don't have a family left
frankly I think he forgotten what I am
never more
the House of Usher
may it rest in peace
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
foreign
what is it about the city of Boston that
leads me to forego the most
sophisticated temptation of the
fermented grape sitting here with a cold
brew in my hand I feel Amalgamated with
the high pillai you are the classic
every man
Freddy surprise dad
here at my door unannounced no there's a
shorter way to say that surprise
what's going on with your son I wish I
knew got a girlfriend I've never even
heard of when I told him I wanted to
spend more time with him he said no it's
just not a good time have you considered
that he hates you
I miss you and I won't take no for an
answer so I'm taking a drop and I found
a place to live my dad I mean he can be
kind of
he smelled really yeah he always smells
really good
don't sit down it was our Christian
Lacroix pillows so we cast it on the
couch not in jeans
we are here
salads and scrambled eggs what do you
say we have a toast I got some Scotch
that sounds good great dog go get it
tough shelf of course nothing less no
it's on the top shelf of the hutch green
plastic jug
but I don't know what to do with those
tossed salads and scrambled eggs today
I'm spending time with my son colleagues
and friends for the first time in my
life I can say that Frasier Crane wants
for nothing oh that's too bad I had
somebody that I wanted to set you up
with I'm gonna be ready in five minutes
[Music]
in life
Discovery is usually lead to more
questions
the only constant variable is the
unexpected we can't control it
it's only when you look backwards that
you see how it was all connected
let's begin shall we
that's perfect I like to cook it's just
chemistry
you're on the verge of a major
scientific breakthrough this institution
has a reputation based on the
world-class scientists not the theories
of a pretty lab tech we have rules
you're firing me
just stop you're crying it's a sign of
the times
I would like to offer you a job as the
host of our cooking show are you
concussed
because you are poised to become a TV
star welcome to the final show we're
live in five four three welcome viewers
this is supper at six
[Music]
do I need a catchphrase don't overthink
it never understood what that meant I
stand proudly with the overlooked
Workhorse of the kitchen women and baked
potatoes
[Music]
you've got something almost no one has
the platform
what you say matters politics don't
belong in the kitchen a man wants his
wife to make him a drink after a long
day at work why do you assume that his
day was longer than hers why don't you
make the drink
[Music]
you are what I treasure most in this
world not because you are pretty not
because you are smart but because you
love me and I love you
parents do you think you can't do it and
you do it anyway
your ability to change everything starts
here
children's at the table your mother
needs a moment to herself
have we met Nathan Brad I'm the new
English teacher
you live near here
yeah the old Biddle house
The Brew House
I did hear the horrible story about the
boy who used to live there
you know I hear it's haunted
have you seen anything
strange happening there
no
not that I can think of
[Music]
some weird stuff has been happening
something's clearly wrong
why would you do that man that's not
cool there's no such thing as a curse
dude that isn't real
[Music]
are you okay
this is all connected he's getting
revenge for what our parents did to him
oh my God remember Napo babies
what's going on it's obvious you know
that's why all of this is happening to
us
[Music]
we have no choice this ends now
it's time for them to learn the truth
come with me
oh my God we need to talk why does James
smell like watermelon Jolly Ranchers
I'm rehabilitated
I've learned my lesson I am no longer a
danger to society
okay well you never get a second chance
to make a first impression
so let's stick to the story no Ghosts no
demons you've had a mental breakdown
while you're writing your book
and now you're recovered that is the
story yep just like that
I'm home and I'm in control well Jake
and I don't need you and Dad doesn't
remember you was I a good husband well
Terry you were the best
I really want to focus on this family
anyone are in favor of that [__] no no
thanks
what'd you think would happen darling
get your brains scrambled and life would
be perfect that's what you'll talk about
on the book tour I don't want to be some
mental patient on display I'm not that
person anymore
[Music]
hello dear Bonnie are you okay I tear
you see her yeah
what if my psychosis got into the family
I need to remember what happened
something is wrong with me
I feel like I'm losing control maybe
you're a genius Ryder
thank you to Pat Phelps for reading that
dirty pretty chapter this is Phelps will
now signed copies of her book before it
gets banned
Pat you let me in and there's no Escape
I'd give anything to make this all good
again hi Pat I could help you
but it'll cost you
you
[Applause]
[Music]
hey look Morty I'm a leg a leg Morty any
progress I found the version of me that
killed my wife you just missed it
can I ask if you're currently a hologram
yeah yeah hold on one sec
[Music]
I'm sober
and drinking on a Thursday
[Music]
how long does a society take to collapse
let's find out
I'm telling you man you're making a big
mistake here who's ready for Rick's
famous spaghetti
no you didn't set it quietly shut up Dad
you had a job interview right
I was wondering if you could help me out
with a bit of a rake situation a rake
situation
[Applause]
well that last one was just for shock
value
[Music]
what do you say Rick Supply through
space come upon something maybe I have a
moral objection Rick and Morty we're
back baby Rick and Morty new season
premieres Sunday October 15th at 11 PM
only on Adult Swim
how come groups of rich men get to
decide what's right and what's wrong
portrayal of America
that's why I'm here
you're really the kid ain't you
we run things here now
it's getting real dangerous here in
Lincoln
corrupt
the fact that we are now effectively at
War
the other side has the advantage your
foreigners Jesse Evans and his gang are
all practice killers
sharp and I feel like scalping someone
we do what we want boys
if I want Justice I have to take the law
into my own hands
I don't want you or any of these people
to die for me I need to know who the
hell is Billy the Kid
how can I get to him
a new sheriff
they will hunt you down is that what you
want I don't have a choice
the next time I'll see your face will be
in I wanted poster
you're a Survivor Billy you knew at the
moment I saw you
just remember things don't always turn
out
the way you want them to
[Music]
there will be a lot of bloodshed
and let there be bloodshed
have a war to win
[Music]
I promise to love every part of you
forever
my girlfriend is six months pregnant oh
congratulations
do you know what you're having
my stepmom's a werewolf
my name's Detective Kate Cross or we've
had a new piece of information for a
homicide investigation did you see these
gentlemen
why are you asking hi Daddy hello who's
the hot guy hello you're not from here
Anton you said teach me in college did
he help in any other way what do you
mean I mean like did he help you with
his penis oh my God Gary
why are you here I'm here for you
you need to stay away from me because
I'm gonna protect my pack
[Music]
ing maybe the universe is trying to tell
us that this is too dangerous
[Applause]
I love you and that is the only one that
matters
the universe can go and eat a bag of
dicks it's the most romantic thing
anyone's ever said to me
what do you mean say the question out
loud oh how do I feel about graduating
Middle School
Middle School is famously the worst time
of your life I am locked the [__] in
it's second period can we stop with the
screaming Alex Jones sit down [__] I
mean that's the whole show that's what
we're doing please do not break the
fourth wall we just had it repaired
I cannot believe my legacy is gonna be
grossest human
I think it's a compliment oh [__] you're
the goat the grossest of all time who
cares what all these [__] think yeah
[__] this place it smells like a
straight man's butthole I wish you both
Bliss
[__] you Jay I don't wapless I want
erotic chaos uh I'm gonna drop don't
finish
High School is where you're supposed to
fall well I'm with Elijah and he's not
interested in that
drama
foreign
start private school I think maybe Danny
likes me oh
hormones monsters Megan is here
does he get your [__] wet oh my God we
just met is that all you care about uh
duh [__] 100
even our changes they're going through
changes
that's March you saved him that was a
very bad Mitten seriously what the [__]
Going Global baby
[Music]
laugh but the world peace
a dick and suck it do it Andrew suck it
what a gorgeous day you are gorgeous
oh don't stop on my account
did you guys hook up was it everything
you thought it would be she seems like a
bit of a pillow princess let's just say
we had an amazing connection
how long have you been downloaded 26
days
so what are you doing here everybody
else hold hundreds of innocent people
we're gonna break it and shut it down I
have a plan promise me you won't say
anything the more people that know about
it the more dangerous it is no no no no
he's nowhere in the system so I rebooted
him from a backup copy
there is another you living in Lakeview
you think this is identity theft
this means I have a second chance to do
things right new Nathan doesn't remember
breaking up with me for someone who has
great skin you do a lot of concealing to
Nathan's one Nora never fantasized about
this before
[Music]
it's not like it's cheating it's just
your boyfriend six months ago back when
he was a little more into you
[Music]
I think that your girl is hanging with
my fake dude
so it's just crazy for me to be jealous
of me everybody's jealous of you you're
like Gaston times 50 million but good
and hotter
Ingrid owns this body
Horizon owns my thoughts
my heart that belongs to you
there's a big problem with the AI what
are you doing taking time off you don't
get time off I was told to act more
human-like to be human is to avoid work
you're a thing like a screwdriver my bad
back to work then Lord help me
[Music]
thank you
Maddie's been taken
tell me what I'm supposed to do
[Music]
Harry we have to do this the right way
you have to
I don't
thank you
I know the police have been looking for
me
the missing officer
is she alive well I'm not gonna tell you
that
we want to find her just as much as you
do I doubt that very much you have no
idea what I'm feeling right now
you got to let us do our job don't cut
me out
of it where's my daughter
[Music]
emperor
satanico
okay
[Applause]
the only way to know the exact date and
time of the end of the world is to
provoke it ourselves
foreign
[Music]
he's got the
foreign
[Music]
I'm offering you as the opportunity to
start from scratch in a new world I
don't want to seem arrogant but I would
love to show you what I'm capable of
course
Roberto
sometimes
[Music]
like before